[MUSIC PLAYING]
ADDY OSMANI: So do
you know that thing
where you're given a
budget, and basically it's
enough to buy a
few cans of soup?
MATT GAUNT: Yep.
ADDY OSMANI: We sort
of spent all of ours
on the animated intro.
MATT GAUNT: But it's
a very nice intro.
ADDY OSMANI: It is.
MATT GAUNT: And we can do this.
ADDY OSMANI: Your leg's on fire.
MATT GAUNT: Ah!
So the reason we're
doing this video
is we've recorded a brand new
season of "Totally Tooling
Tips."
But rather than host it on the
Google Developer channel, which
we're currently
on, we've moved it
over to the Chrome Developer
channel, along with all
the other web content.
ADDY OSMANI: So shows
like "Supercharged,"
and "Polycasts," "HTTP203"--
MATT GAUNT: Yep, and anything
new that might come out.
It's all going to be over there.
So hit the Subscribe
button, which
will be somewhere on the
screen, probably, hopefully.
ADDY OSMANI: Maybe.
MATT GAUNT: But,
yeah, come and check
out our brand new series
of "Totally Tooling Tips."
ADDY OSMANI: Yeah,
"Totally Tooling Tips,"
the show that's been described
as blissfully mediocre.
Thanks, mom.
[MUSIC PLAYING]